voilà c'est un début d'un trop buggé
je cherchais à coeur car je vais rien
faire finalement rien faire c'est quoi
c'est pas quelque chose c'est comme le
vit il n'y a pas de vide
le v10 forcément quelque chose cette
intro philosophique de merde on est
aujourd'hui sur landes entre nous on a
fait tout ce jeu il ya très tiré
plusieurs mois je crois on vient
d'aménager si on a un voisin en face
qu'on suspecte d'être un peu fou voire
même d'emprisonner des gens voire même
de séquestrer les gens c'est la même
chose au final donc j'ai grandement
évolué à parme en de ce que j'ai vu il
ya pas mal de pièces qui sont difficiles
d'accès faut trouver comment y accéder
pour finale au final accéder à la pièce
finale
ça fait beaucoup trop de fois le mot
final dans sa tombe reste est parti de
la glu ça veut peut-être servir à le
régler au sol finalement un réveil à ça
c'est pour l'attirer je me souviens ça
fait du bruit ok on peut prendre lâché
aussi beaucoup de façons de base à gérér
donc autant pour une chaise mon gars on
pourra toujours lui envoyer tous ils
cassent les couilles il ya près de la
direccte non non non hop [ __ ] j'aime
pas le remercier de sa maison à 15 euros
et là il ya peut être qu'à trouver non
je suis choqué les oblige à trouver chez
pas encore ce qu'est dolls est qu'on y
avait joué avec par exemple une lampe
une lampe à lumière noire qu'il fallait
trouver pour tous les écritures chars
murs a donné un code pin bref c'est un
des lièges sûr qu'il y aura exactement
la même chose
oh [ __ ] c'est moi j'ai cru qu'ils
étaient des à moi que j'avais vues via
son nom de quoi la panique était totale
alors oui oui c'est exactement ce dont
on rêvait beau ici aura rien donc je
pense qu'on a trouvé le premier truc
encaissé une porte dont max et d'accéder
à la porte m de fuck mec ça sert à quoi
ça je comprends pas moi je sais pas ça
servira peut-être plus tard quelque
chose parfois je peux y avait un bruit
et je peux pas changer d'objets moi je
parle
aux bâtards haut
j'ai réussi à m'enfuir je suis trop
chaud iam sort j'ai réussi à m'enfuir
pour de vrai maintenant ils s'arrêtent
d'accord et vient pas non plus de choper
bâtard bâtir un glou glou savané d'agde
le chicon par contre j'arrive pas changé
d'objet ça c'est chiant ça et un lecteur
de cartes
enfin trouvé une carte pour accéder à
cette porte au québec au genou et yard
étages au lieu de grille je te dise j'ai
envie de chialer jeu c'est pire du ps
dans tes ville bref il y avait un étage
avec une grille s'intéresse à la hausse
est-ce qu'on peut pas y aller les
escaliers ok donc c'est là qu'il faut
que j'aille je pense qu'il ya moyen
essayer de faire un saut un truc non
c'est faire un saut genre à chercher un
moyen hop
si le resserrement de la hoya kouassi et
un cadenas au maire je suis visé au plus
tôt et manichéen hockey de données
marché à ça et on ya une pote haganah ok
c'est forcément par là c'est forcément
vers la tv qui a vu un pour cent de la
maison c'est forcément par là etc sont
fiés aux mannequins au milieu du couloir
avec mythe qui fait sa [ __ ] oh c'est
bon j'ai démarré mon coeur il ya des
chênaies ça abusé [ __ ] on va péter
hume 7 et qu'une chaussure vas-y je suis
je suis des terres je suis des terres
personne pourra m'arrêter
ok ok waouh
zuma a tenté par là là tu là dessus oh
ouais
gobeil s'appuyer là-dessus quoi je suis
allé au culot ça a marché j'ai vécu lors
d'une poignée pour ouvrir la grille mais
la pire idée de la planète voit jamais
faire ça alors qu'est ce qu'un des
recettes portes du coup si on trouve des
choses
en tout cas il pourra pas arriver de la
cie vient de là avec sa house et j'ai
peur chez sa mère ce [ __ ] de viol on
l'a bien c'est ça que j'ai mal joué au
fait que j'ose bruit plein à quoi s'est
fermé auquel on a quoi c'est un cadenas
avec avec un cadenas en or faudrait une
couleur nord du coup un mec c'est à dire
que c'est forcément par la cua dai
qu'est-ce que [ __ ] ici se tait à
gauche il ya une porte là peut-être
qu'on voit pas à temps d'attenté maire
depuis j'ai perdu la lite emmerdes
c'était par la bataille les l'argentin
faire très vite hu j'ai fait le fric
avec mon voisin voilà ses manières de
faire connaissance finalement je pense
qu'on est sur la bonne piste mais y'a un
truc qu'on a omis de faire ce qui me
permette celui parlé comme ça si vous
permettez parler comme ça en fait là
haut
regardez il ya un petit switch à activer
et normalement ça ouvrira ce truc là et
de d'ailleurs à la clé pour vous avez
ouvre la can et un orc on a vu tout à
l'heure
le truc c'est que c'est super choix à
faire et qu'en plus on n'est jamais à
l'abri que le mec se pointe genre tout
moment qu'on va prendre deux cartons et
la table we will arrive la rue lajoie
j'ai préféré partir
voilà que le cliché d'un second aux
[ __ ] par bono vers le truc à manger
pour accéder à la clé je vais pouvoir
accéder je sais qu'à droite notamment je
peux trouver une sorte d'aimant qui
attire les quais et ça m'aiderait
beaucoup je besoin de remonter sur ma
table de merde faire ici dia impute un
objet normalement vers la vers cet
endroit
bien sûr je le trouve pas oui oh yes man
band take dugourd après mon gars je veux
attirer la clé est clément et tu vas
être dégoûté
oui maintenant on monte on fait comme on
a fait tout à l'heure ok je vous la
grippe ce que sera pas simple pour
revenir vu qu'on va se foirer dans moins
d'une seconde
ok ce parti entend c'est [ __ ] mais ce
sont les durs la fille des kalachs ta
[ __ ] mais attendez je suis quoi en
fait on peut on peut ouvrir le canada le
cadenas d'or il et il n'est pas faux pas
faire le saut pour y accéder bompard n'a
pas le temps de passer là bas c'est mort
nique ta mère
pardon je disais donc la chambre avec le
[ __ ] de ganador j'avais oublié mais
elle est là en fait voilà ça nous a vus
d'avoir faire ce saut voilà donc ici on
a deux portons à celle là ouais une
baignoire avec rien dedans avec train de
cacher dans les tiroirs ya quoi il ya
bien évidemment absolument rien et dans
cette deuxième porte il y à des tableaux
des tableaux des tableaux et un grand
espace et attends je vais juste posé ça
là haut il porte tout seul c'est un
piège
ah oui ça mène à mais oui ça amène en
bas aux caisses totalement un piège bat
enseigne ouzbeks
cet endroit est nul je suis venu là pour
air la porte dorée là on s'en bat les
couilles
elle ne sert à rien on s'est battu pour
avoir cette clé pour rien par contre je
veux réussir ce tube mais c'est de la
physique du jeu elle est nulle et du
coup j'ai du coup j'arrive vraiment pas
à faire ce saut quoi c'est une tnt
preuve de ce qu'il est on connaît mon
skill ok j'ai compris je crois qu'en
fait faut vraiment sauté il a mis des
lasers il a mis une caméra là comme un
nom comme ça entre deux sauts comme fo
gardant qu'il a empoché bricorama quoi
servent ces noms
non il est là mais [ __ ] est en train
de péter un câble à j'arrive pas à faire
ce [ __ ] de ceux-là physique est
dégueulasse est impossible voilà avec ça
sorte [ __ ] je me sens mieux je me sens
existent et la la regardez regardez le
mec comme il fait ça en une seconde le
mec ville step 17 jay l'a fait il a fait
ces étapes avant nous on a fait 2 oz il
court et il saute vraiment au dernier
moment sa mère mais genre c'est une
manif de ouf non lotie quand wayne va
t'acheter [ __ ] de vie en plus il est
buggé là on doit aller maintenant je
vais débloqués il galère à l'eau et des
blocs toi au sila bah oui développement
mais voilà mais voilà après ce jeu c'est
un jeu de grande qualité
alors on est d'accord il est vraiment
buggé dans la fenêtre nathan du coup je
peux passer là en fait est-ce que la
chance nous sourit
est-ce que là vraiment on notera d'avoir
la chance mais non mais c'est incroyable
si je veux live vient pas mais non mais
la chance qu'on a mais oui mais oui
alors attention cette fois c'est la
bonne je le sens
[Musique]
vous rendez compte il ya pas eu de bug
du gua sans déconner quoi on était là
demain donc la norme en france tire
cette merde qu'est ce qu'il ya bîmes
c'est incroyable ya vraiment une clé on
la chope et vous savez la clé de quoi c
est ce que vous savez la clé de quoi
c'est moi oui on va y aller deux se bat
pendant clouté buggé comme un bon gros
cons là il ya cette porte subventionné
ça dégage
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas découvrir ce
qu'ils adhèrent cette porte qui vous
fera découvrir pourquoi depuis 2h ou
galère c'est tout c'est tout à temps là
il ya un truc relié à ça je sais pas
quoi c'est quoi ce délire lors qu'est ce
qui se passe je rectifie ça ça monte et
ça peuvent accéder à cette porte est bon
on va le faire on va le faire belle
jusqu'au braille est rappelé à m elle
avait nous cette trappe toi je vais
regarder maintenant qu'on a fait le truc
chiant de la vidéo de manière on peut
bien moi je tombais où là c'est quoi
cette trempe mon gars ailleurs shotgun
that fucking you may easing voix par se
venger ou avoir baisé lauga qui est la
cause de tous nos maux et là on a le
temps d'accord joie on est ok je vais
remonter j'ai compris ce qu'il faut
faire ça va encore être une manip chien
au bon dieu
j'avais pas vu devant la grille du
refuge et un pompier à la carte pour
accéder au toucan bas qu'y at il
derrière cette porte secrète
le peuple de france sur le demande au
caire des boissons sucrés attention ça
les hyper vite aussi attention attention
mais la bande avec the mojos raid
incroyable sévère on ouvre la porte et
ses paroles je sais c'est par ap don't
panic never panique ne l'est pas ni la
caméra est revenu c'est une excellente
nouvelle on va dans la pièce jerrycans
adoré que j'ai ouvert d'autres temps on
passe par la fenêtre son intérêt ici on
shoppe l'échelle même si on fait un
mètre vingt
voilà tout est faisable même en faisant
un mètre vingt voyant vos rêves on
atteint cet endroit on accède à ça on
monte sur la table basse
au soudan la fenêtre on a ici un pied de
biche
on passe par là résistons aux fc bakou
terme incertain mais c'est quand paris
invité y est j'ai eu peur qu'il meure
mais ces bons est là avec nous
ici je n'ai rien à [ __ ] que des objets
le voit rouge de consoles j'ai gravi des
fenêtres j'ai tenté un soin avec une
physique bogey plus de 600 fois tout ça
pour voir un mec chialait j'arrête
youtube non mais lucas ne vois-tu donc
pas ce pauvre homme ça montre que malgré
ses airs de méchant au fond cet homme
souffre tu ne connais pas son passé tu
ne peux pas le critiquer fa ba et met la
vidéo est là je vous fais un braquage de
j'aime ta pas aimé bon ben ali ça fait
deux heures que je joue ça fait deux
heures que je joue un [ __ ] l'élan ça
m'a rendu fou je suis content j'avais ma
petite fierté je voulais finir le jeu
mais c'était galère imaginez s'il avait
pas pau qui s'il n'était pas coincé dans
un mur à l'est avec un bon jeu vidéo va
se regarder les aider à sa vous a plu
portez vous bien d'autres pistes
[Musique]